um good morning uh members U and those
others that have joined us today uh
record my name's Mark mccon took me a
moment to see my room back with a with a
wall and sitting in this configuration
and uh for years serving in here I can't
tell you how excited I am about that
well there aren't so many that are
enjoying their rooms back but we
are um I'd like to uh and I apologize
for for being six minutes late here I'd
like to start the capital project
overview
committee um and um first order of
business would be nomination of a we
have new membership uh there was a
change and um I would like to start the
process with a nomination of a vice
chair if I could recognize Karen eel for
nomination thank you very much Mr chair
it's my pleasure to nominate
representative Mills uh to be Vice chair
of this committee I
second thank you
Senator um are there any further
nominations seeing none uh if you're in
favor of the motion Mills to be uh Vice
chairman signified by saying I I any
opposed uh pass is unanimous uh we now
are in search of a clerk Mr chair um
representative Mel I would like to
nominate representative Danny
clerk please thank you is there a
second second by wer thank you um any
clerk uh seeing none if you're in favor
of the motion of
uh uh for clerk signified by saying I I
all those
opposed R what a pleasure to have a new
clerk thank you I used to like all of
you
oh you got cams down
there there you
go all right there has been a change in
our agenda a couple items are falling
off of that um and I will
uh we will get to that in just a
you ready there uh excuse me uh new
business uh before us uh RSA
12463 Harbor dredging and peer
maintenance fund established uh the
request is
2320 peace uh Development Authority
division of ports and
harbors authorization to expend up to
$100,000 from the harbor dredging and
Pier maintenance fund subject approval
of PDA of directors purpose of funding
repairs to the pier at the Portsmouth
commercial fish Pier um G welcome please
introduce yourself uh thank you Mr
chairman members of the committee for
the record Gan Omar con and I am the
director of the peace Development
Authority division of ports and
harbit affectionately known as the Port
Authority um this request comes as a
result of us going out to public bid to
do repairs at the Portsmouth commercial
fish Pier uh we did get some good bids
good bids in um but we were a little bit
short of the money uh and in instead of
uh taking away one of the adults in the
contract or in the bid process uh
requesting to use some of the money out
of the hybrid dredge Pian maintenance
fund so we can do the complete project
and not leave one of the squares off the
checker board um the the commercial Pier
was built in uh
1977 uh and it's the cross bracing and
some of the structural pieces under the
pier and the deck on the pier
interestingly enough when we redid the
seaw wall that AB buts the pier we had
to take a row of the pilings out um
because the the new wall was put a few
feet out we took the pilings out and put
them in the parking lot and we sliced
them to see what the condition there was
and uh we were all just completely
shocked that the pilings were looked
like they were brand new after all of
these years so uh we went back in and we
red we Revisited the uh the what we were
going to go out to bed and we remove
that portion of replacing the pilings
and we just doing the cross bracing and
the deck and some of the fixtures on it
which uh reduce the price down to what
we have today but we were just short a
little bit of money and uh that's that's
the purpose of By Request here
today thank you uh questions from the
members yes represent delandro I thank
you very much Mr chairman G know
um how how are things that we PA the
peer the the peer that that was falling
apart a couple of years ago the that
that were de the bridge that's all set
down yes you mean you mean the main ship
war right right yes by me Mr chairman um
actually first of the week we got the
notice from the contractor substantially
complete um so they're just doing a
couple of uh punch list items on it but
um that was uh 20 years is in the making
yeah and there was further question
please there was no problem with the
fuel
lines there seem to be some concern but
initially but that's okay everything is
okay down in Ry we had some trouble with
the fuel lines uh it's just it's the
atmosphere in which it can you know the
uh being in the salt water and the storm
surge and everything uh that that's just
the nature of the Beast down at R Harbor
with the fuel lines we we try to do what
we we can uh do preventive construction
and preventive maintenance on it but uh
saltwater has a very corrosive effect
sure thank you you sir thank thank you
Mr thank you further
questions seeing none do we have a
motion I would move the
item um mve by delandro seconded
by uh wer uh any further
discussion if you're in favor of the um
approval for item number
23020 signified by saying I I any
opposed motion carries thank you thank
you Mr chairman members of the committee
and have a great holiday and enjoy your
families while you're at it thank great
great Jobo thank you always for
C state just uh we can't be more
complimentary for the work that he's
done over the last 100 years that's
that's all better of that point Thank
You Tito thank you I would agree sander
but I I don't want my wife to hear the
comment that you were a little short and
$100,000 thank you sir thank
you
um yes Mr sh repr mcon you want to
accept the minutes from the last meeting
you s gray thank you second Mo motion
made by gray seconded by Mills to accept
the minutes from September 15 is that
the ones we're looking for any
discussion Corrections
omissions if you're in favor of the
opposed
you motion
carries um we have um informational item
um
2321 Mr
Shay thank you represent mononi so the
informational item is the quarterly
report that um we discussed in length at
the meeting in September um the
Department of Transportation you'll see
that there's a letter from them that's
item
23022 originally the plan had been for
the Department to come and um discuss
with you some of their concerns and
questions around the quarterly report if
you look at the item uh
23021 near the back there's a a DOT
addition to that quarterly report um by
making the name from capital budget to
capital projects over viw the department
and setting the threshold that we did at
the last meeting at projects of a
million or more it added uh several
hundred projects that the Department of
Transportation would need to report on
so they just wanted to come before this
committee to get a little bit um clearer
guidance due to timing because I
anticipated it would be a little bit of
a discussion um the chair agreed that we
should postpone this until the next
meeting which I think is planned
potentially for January
26 um and so that's why the Department's
not here today I had made them aware
that um there would probably not be a
discussion related to this after talking
with the chair and the same thing
happened with fishing game in terms of
they were going to do an update on the
online registration for ohrv today um
again due to the short time and the
confusion with the membership um we were
concerned that um we wouldn't have
enough time to finish that and that
there might be questions or people
wouldn't be prepared to have a
discussion today so that's all I have on
that unless anybody question share
myself on
that uh we are U with with the change in
membership we are now with sitting with
uh more from finance and we appreciate
that opportunity here that should do
nothing but help us shouldn't it David
right okay thank you all right um so
other than setting the next meeting date
which Mr Shay had alluded to January 26
is there any other business that uh
time right so without objection and if
if if there's scheduling problems please
get back to us we'll tedly set our next
uh Capital project overview committee
meeting for January
26 at 9:00 am at 900 am Mr Shay thank
motion move been seconded to
adjourn um if you're in favor of that
motion signify by saying I I any opposed
time